From the beginning, Juul products were a hit.
It was easy to use, came in different colors and flavors, and at one time,...
...it had 75 percent market share, but now, its future is in doubt.
Bad news for Altria, the cigarette company that owns a 35 percent stake,...
…but good news perhaps for firms like R. J. Reynolds,...
...whose vuse e-cigarettes already have approval to remain on the market.
So, what exactly happened?
The U.S. Food and Drug Administration...
...has ordered Juul to stop selling its e-cigarette device...
...and four types of Juul pods in America, its biggest market,...
...pointing to its role in fueling an epidemic of teenage vaping.
The decision comes nearly two years...
...after the company submitted its application to the FDA...
...with the hopes of continuing to sell their products.
However, the agency concluded...
...that Juul had failed to prove their products met legal standards,...
...saying they had provided insufficient and conflicting data,...
...especially about potential harmful chemicals leaching from Juul pods.